heute geht es also weiter mit der
aussage von bushido was wird für heute
erwartet
heute wird erwartet dass er den zeitraum
2004 bis 2007 dem gericht erklären will
was er und wie er mit arafat abou chaker
und seinen brüdern zusammen gearbeitet
hat da wird auch erwartet werden dass es
da womöglich auch um
schwarzgeldzahlungen geht und das könnte
die anderen straftaten seien die in
anderen behörden sowie hat die
staatsanwältin formuliert derzeit
bearbeitet werden er hatte schon einen
hinweis gegeben
diese 30.000 euro zahlen beispiel von
100.000 müsste ja 30.000 arafat bezahlen
und nach steuer bleiben ihnen dann
selber nur 20.000 diese 30.000 hat er
womöglich der arafat abou chaker gar
nicht versteuert und das könnte jetzt
hier sehr interessant werden dieses jahr
wie gefährlich sind generell die
aussagen von bushido jetzt für arafat
abou chaker und seine familie
naja jetzt geht's jetzt geht es in die
heiße phase er wird heute auch schon bis
2007 da gibt es dann auch schon die
ersten retter nahmen die anderen
verträge wie arafat sich womöglich in
das musikgeschäft weiter etabliert hat
ob es dann noch weitere
nebenkriegsschauplätze geht das ist sehr
interessant
die anwälte der
großfamilie die werden versuchen mit
anträgen weiter die glaubwürdigkeit von
bushido einzuschränken und zu schwächen
insbesondere einfluss auf die
laienrichter die schöffen zu machen dass
die das nicht ganz so bewerten ansonsten
ist das leben für ihn ich sag mal voller
entbehrungen und einschränkungen auch er
kann nicht mal eben in ein sportstudio
gehen oder mit seinen kindern ein eis
essen gehen
das ist sehr bedrohlich